[MUSIC]
My sister Fernando and
I grew up loving animals.
Our best family vacation was
a trip to Disney's Animal Kingdom.
I was five years old and
I went on the safari ride.
When I saw the reenactment of poachers
trying to steal a baby elephant,
my heart beat so hard,
I still remember how hard it bounded.
When the elephant was rescued,
this was Disney after all.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I cried with relief.
Little did I know that one day Fernando
and I would have our own rescue mission.
Six years ago, we met a tiger.
He was living in this small town in Mexico
in a public park where the government
couldn't afford to pay for his medication.
His home was a windowless concrete hut,
full of old, filthy hay.
The tiger's name was Rajah,
which means Indian king.
But Rajah wasn't the sort of
majestic creature you'd expect
to see in a Disney movie.
He was so weak, he couldn't even stand up.
He had red raw open source on his legs.
When I looked at Rajah and I really
look into his deep dive watery eyes,
I could feel his misery.
And all I wanted to do was to take
him out of that concrete prison and
find a place where he could go and
be healthy and safe again.
Trying to find such a place, Fernando and
I contacted a number of sanctuaries.
Finally, one in Colorado
agreed to take Rajah.
After countless meetings and phone calls
and paperwork over an eight week period,
we finally convince the Mexican
government to let go of Rajah.
But before we could do the transport,
Rajah died.
When Fernando and I heard the news,
we held each other and
we decided that we do
everything we could to prevent
other animals from sharing
Rajah's unhappy ending.
In 2015, we had our first test.
Mexico's Congress passed a well
intentional law that bans animal
performances from services.
From one day to another 1200
animals needed a new place to live.
The lack of suitable places
to relocate these animals
resulted in the death of 1,000 of them.
Fernando and
I started a social media campaign.
We contacted international sanctuaries and
we talked to the Mexican authorities.
And then we learned that this was
just the tip of the ice berg.
In the part 15 years in Mexico alone,
45,000 wild
animals have been victims of abuse,
exploitation and wild life trade.
And the ones that were lucky enough to be
rescued, didn't have a safe place to go.
Sadly, this is a problem
that goes far beyond Mexico.
According to the World's Wildlife
Organization, environmental degradation
together with illegal wildlife trade
has lead to an extinction rate between
a 1000 and 10,000 times higher
than the natural extinction rate.
Since 1976, we;'ve wiped out 60,
60% of the world wildlife.
Recently, the last male white rhino died.
There are still two female
white rhinos in the planet.
But when they die,
the whole species will be gone forever.
The heart of the problem lies in the lack
of awareness about wildlife conservation.
In some cultures, rhino horn is
used as it was a miracle cure.
In others, ivory is a symbol of status.
But it's not just exotic
products that harm wild life.
If you use shampoo or eat ice cream,
these everyday products
typically contain palm oil.
Every hour,
rain forest area equivalent to 300
soccer fields are being
lost to palm oil farming,
leaving hundreds of wild animals and
endangered species homeless.
Thankfully, most of the time when
people learn about the negative
consequences their behaviors have,
they start caring.
Each one of us in this room can make
a difference by changing some of our
behaviors.
In 2017, Fernando and
I decided to built Latin America's
first wildlife sanctuary to house and
rehabilitate abused wild animals.
Located in 50 acres in
the center of Mexico,
San Tuay is being designed to
accommodate 200 wild animals,
including bears, elephants and big cats.
Through the best veterinary practices and
top notch facilities,
our sanctuary will provide these animals
with a healthy and safe place to live.
In San Tuay, visitors will be able to
witness the consequences of illegal
wildlife trade and
environmental degradation.
But they will also learn ways in which
they can contribute to the solution.
Our end goal is to replicate this
kind of sanctuaries across the world.
Currently, we're in the process
of raising funds, and hopefully,
in a few months, we will be able
to start building a place that
will change the lives of
hundreds of wild animals.
But most importantly, the behaviors and
minds of thousands of visitors.
However, you don't have to build
a wildlife sanctuary to make a difference.
Minor changes in your
everyday habits could
save the lives of
hundreds of wild animals.
A few people have asked me, why should
I care about saving wild animals?
Well, let me tell you.
Biodiversity is fundamental for
a healthy ecosystem.
A healthy ecosystem is fundamental for
a healthy and sustainable economy.
These animals are a fundamental
part of that biodiversity.
But mostly I just want to show
them a picture of Rajah, to me,
the reason why we need to save
these animals is self-evident.
There are many things you can
do to help protect wild animals.
But today,
I want you to leave with three in mind.
First, reduce food waste,
40% of the food grown on
the planet is wasted.
Growing that food destroys habitats, so
let's not grow so much more than we need.
Second, buy environmentally
responsible products.
Look at the ingredients,
make sure they are responsibly
sourced especially if
it contains palm oil.
Third, reduce meat consumption,
try to shift from red to white meat.
The livestock industry is responsible for
a disproportionate amount of
annual habitat destruction.
And then you can always volunteer or
donate to sanctuaries like mine.
[LAUGH] Today I feel very lucky to
be a part of the GSB community.
People like you have the power
to inspire thousands of others.
Through the companies you will create,
through the policies you will influence,
and through the children you will raise.
Let's all work together in creating real
life happy endings for animals like Rajah.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]